fires burn through the night following
an attack on saudi aramco oil refineries
and storage facilities
it's the second attack in as many days
on a major complex on the outskirts of
jeddah
by daybreak on saturday with plumes of
smoke still billowing above the city the
saudi-led coalition had launched
retaliatory strikes across the border
into yemen
the coalition says the iran-backed
rebels struck jeddah in another facility
in jazan to try and impact the nerve
center of the world economy
aramco facilities in jeddah as well as
vital facilities in the saudi enemy's
capital riyadh were targeted with a
barrage of winged missiles ras tanura
and rabbi oil refineries were targeted
by a huge number of drones
the facility is 20 kilometers from
jetta's race circuit where drivers were
practicing for saudi arabia's second
formula one grand prix
uh it's not a bit of a burning feeling
that i'm the truth is my car or another
car
organizers say the race will go ahead on
sunday saudi officials maintain the
attacks have no impact on daily life in
jeddah
the houthis have rejected a gulf
cooperation council proposal for talks
in riyadh but say they could happen in a
neutral country
materially speaking it doesn't cause
enough damage to qualify as a strategic
hit when whenever they hit
targets uh that either in saudi arabia
or the uae
it's a hit against tourism in these
countries that you can't run
car races and international games
as if nothing is happening while we are
under siege
and while we are being struck on a daily
basis from the air
uh so it certainly
alarms people who are visiting
this area because they never know when
these rockets are going to hit
across the border houthi media outlets
say eight people were killed in one
strike in yemen's capital sana
war is now in its eighth year the u.n
says it has killed more children under
the age of five than combatants on the
battlefield
the u.n believes 377 000 yemenis have
died as a result of direct causes like
air strikes and indirect causes like
hunger and preventable disease what aid
agencies describe as true hell on earth
and on saturday tens of thousands of
people poured into the streets in sada
and other houthi-controlled areas to
mark what they called national
resilience day and protest against the
conflict
andrew chappelle al jazeera